[Musique]
bienvenue à rhymes sidi un havre de paix
où humains y pokémon vivent en parfaite
harmonie des mains
ton père était une légende de la police
et si tu tiens de lui vraiment pas je me
souviens tu voulais être dresseur de
pokémon quand tu étais petit
ouais bah finalement ça l'a pas fait
[Musique]
il ya quelqu un je ne sais pas qui est
là mais je vous préviens je suis armé
allez c'est parti je sais que tu peux
pas comprendre ce que je dis mais pose
ton agrafeuse ou sinon je vais télé
procu t'es ok attends tu parles
une seconde a compris ce que j'ai dit
voilà face à lui si tu me comprends que
je me sentais tellement sauver les gens
veulent tout le temps de parler mais ils
entendent juste pica pica vous
l'entendez comme moi vous l'entendez
pica pica pica il adorable tu es
adorable puisque dalle mon pote personne
d'autre
je veux pas de pokémon point barre
si je te dis que je suis un grand
détective parce que si tu veux retrouver
ton vieux je suis ton meilleur atout
on va y arriver toi et moi
à magic qui nous a réunis et cette magie
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'espoir
écoute on a les moyens de te faire
parler ou mi mai ouais alors dit nous ce
qu'on veut savoir à neuf turcs as une
casserole
tu la pousse tu crois que je repousse
les gens et qu'après je leur en veux
partir il te dit d'aller de faire cuire
un oeuf bardon qui savoie où ça suffit
j'en ai marre on échange nos rôles je
suis le méchant flic étoile jaune
j'imaginais ça différemment dans ma tête
[Musique]